once upon a time New York City's
builders blithely turned spectacular
monuments into dust
Henry James complained about Manhattan's
Restless renewals but in the old days
nostalgia was for writers and poets
developers were preoccupied with
building the future this ethos of
creative destruction allowed New York to
become the world's pre-eminent city and
then 50 years ago this Sunday Mayor
Robert F Wagner signed the Landmarks
Preservation Act the law made it illegal
to destroy any structure that the city's
planning elite deemed too important not
to save today almost a third of the
buildings in Manhattan and more than
33,000 structures citywide may as well
be encased in a life-sized historical
diorama to illustrate the damage done by
this law let's imagine that the
landmarks Act had been passed not in
1965 but in 1865 when the spire of
Trinity Church still towered over lower
Manhattan modern New York wouldn't exist
consider Henry Hardin Berg's original
Waldorf Astoria which was an
architectural masterpiece and
Manhattan's leading luxury hotel if the
Landmarks Commission had been around in
the Jazz Age surely it would have
protected this great structure and then
it never could have been torn down to
build the Empire State Building which
occupies the exact same spot
if the Landmarks Commission had been
around to save architects Stanford
White's majestic Madison Square Garden
the second of four structures with that
name Cass Gilbert's New York Life
Insurance Building couldn't have
replaced it forget about the hustle of
midtown Manhattan this entire block
would still be home to Columbia
University's pre 1897 campus the old
London Terrace would have cleared a path
to the New London Terrace instead of the
Woolworth Building Philip owns luxurious
townhouse would still stand right here
next to the old American Hotel and we
might still have this old church instead
of the celebrated Met Life Tower the
Landmarks Commission not only protects
individual buildings but also a hundred
and fourteen districts meaning entire
neighborhoods are essentially frozen in
time Manhattan's Upper West Side became
a landmark district in 1994 what if it
had earned that distinct
in 1890 to preserve its Gilded Age
character these hulking apartment
buildings would never replace the
distinguished brownstones and mansions
that once occupied these blocks the
district certainly would have expanded
one block west to include Apthorp house
which quartered General Washington among
other colonial big woods and would still
stand right here near 90th Street and
Columbus Avenue before landmarking sure
there were plenty of great buildings
replaced by plain-jane skyscrapers but
that's also part of how cities grow and
evolve for example would New York really
be better off if temple Emanuel still
stood right off Times Square in 1847
native New Yorker Washington Irving
reflected with nostalgia and growing up
in a city that was a mere corner of what
it had become and that corner all
changed pulled to pieces this 50th
anniversary of the landmark Preservation
Act is an opportunity to mourn the
opposite all the invisible buildings
that will never exist because of a
misguided law what if an earlier
generation had outlawed the rise of
skyscrapers and spread of asphalt
pavement Washington Irving would still
feel right at home